tout de suite l'invité de paris direct
[Musique]
et nous recevons ce matin camille
etienne bonjour bonjour merci d'être
avec nous vous êtes une jeune activiste
pour la justice sociale et climatique
vous avez 23 ans vous vous battez au
quotidien pour alerter et convaincre les
dirigeants de l'urgence de la situation
écologique il faut agir et vite vous
utilisez pour cela notamment les réseaux
sociaux votre compte instagram graines
de possibles et votre chaîne youtube
avant l'orage emmanuel macron a été
réélu pour cinq ans alors
qu'attendez-vous du président qu'il
fasse mieux j'imagine que ces cinq
dernières années vous me direz
d'ailleurs peut-être qu'il a de la marge
oui un petit peu disons qu'il a été
condamné pour une action climatique par
la justice et même si lui se défend en
disant qu'il a payé les l'inaction pas
céder de ses prédécesseurs ce qui est
aussi vrai on rappelle quand même qu'il
a créé lui-même ce qu'on appelle la
haute autorité pour le climat donc c'est
lui qui a dit on va prendre des experts
qui vont indépendamment voir si la
politique française et à la hauteur sur
les enjeux climatiques et rapport après
rapport le conseil pour le climat a dit
que ce n'est absolument pas le cas donc
emmanuel macron lui même a dit quand
dans son déplacement à marseille qui
vous fallait aller deux fois plus vite
que lors de son précédent quinquennat
donc en fait déjà rien que tenir ses
promesses ce serait un premier pas
intéressant et et malheureusement on
sait que ça n'a pas été le cas
précédemment par exemple avec la
convention citoyenne pour le climat dont
il a balayé au final toutes les mesures
qui avaient été travaillée qu'il avait
lui même demandé à des citoyens et des
citoyennes qui ont fait un devoir
démocratique très important a été tout
ça a été balayée d'un revers de man sont
ce qu il avait dit aussi déjà lors de sa
précédente campagne sur l'interdiction
du glyphosate n'a pas été tenue donc en
fait voilà j'ai du mal à lui faire
confiance sur ces mesures sur c'est sur
ces annonces de dernière minute comme le
fait d'avoir un premier ministre qui
serait celui des planificateurs écoute
et pourquoi pas je dire ça c'est une
belle idée ça a été défendue par jean
luc mélenchon yannick jadot déjà pendant
cette campagne simplement j'ai du mal à
croire qu'il va être capable cette fois
tenir c'est de tenir ses promesses donc
j'attends d'abord qu'ils tiennent à ce
qui ce qui l'a annoncé et ensuite il ya
tant à faire
justement qu'est-ce que vous proposez
quelles sont les priorités selon vous
sur quoi doit s'attarder le président
emmanuel macron pour moi c'est vraiment
le lien entre la justice sociale et
climatique ça a été le groupe point
faible de ce quinquennat enfin parmi
tant d'autres mais en tout cas l'idée de
comprendre et ça je pense que c'est très
important pour son prochain gouvernement
de comprendre qu'il n'y aura pas de
transition écologique il n'y aura pas de
véritable transformation de la société
si on a fait pas de manière juste c'est
très simple on a voulu faire ils ont
voulu faire une taxe carbone qui était
profondément juste on faisait payer aux
plus précaires le prix de la transition
en disant mais très bien on va vous ne
pourrez plus prendre votre voiture pour
venir de banlieue à paris travaille et
va tant pis pour vous allez payer et
alors qu'on a on a notre notre premier
ministre qui va voter en jet privé là où
le kérosène absolument pas taxées ça
c'est profondément injuste et du coup on
ne peut pas mettre en place des mesures
si elles sont ressentis par la
population française comme urgence
pénalisante d'abord en fait ceux qui ont
moins et je rappelle quand même que il
ya 63 milliardaire en france qui
émettent autant de co2 que 50% de la
population de votre proposition de
marseille rosie sion de dsf climatique
kaki qui n'est pas la mienne d'ailleurs
un cas a été beaucoup porté par
greenpeace par simon populaire par
d'autres candidats et candidates et en
fait c'est l'idée c'est ça c'est de dire
bah on va plus on est responsable plus
on paye parce que plus on est
responsable de la crise plus on est
riche moins on est pompé les
conséquences du dérèglement climatique
elle est là la double injustice c'est à
dire que plus on est responsable de la
catastrophe climatique plus on en est
protégé et ça il faut vraiment changer
dans un message adressé au président à
quand on a pu découvrir chez nos
confrères de brut vous faites bien
comprendre au président que vous ne le
lâcherai pas vous est d'ailleurs tous
ceux qui veulent se battre pour le
climat il ya des genres d'ailleurs
beaucoup de personnes qui vous ont
envoyé des messages suite au second tour
de la présidentielle
qui sont ces personnes en fait qu'ils
voulaient s'engager justement dans le
combat mais en fait c'est très simple on
a eu quand même dépêche de l afp quand
on a vingt trois encore en swing dépêche
de l'efs et qu'il y en a trois ans pour
inverser drastiquement les courbes des
émissions le rapport du rapport du giec
si on veut avoir un monde viable en
réalité il n'est jamais trop tard pour
que ce soit pire je pense qu'on n'a même
pas besoin d'attendre sa pour commencer
parce que derrière chaque dixième de
degré ya des vies en jeu qu'elle soit
humaine
quand on reçoit ça on voit qu'on a un
président qui pendant cinq ans n'a rien
fait voir reculer sur certaines avancées
climatique nous on en parle absolument
pas dans le dans le débat même de
l'entre-deux tours on parle quelques
minutes du climat est en réalité on
parle que du nucléaire et de l'énergie
on ne parle pas des agriculteurs de nos
sols des transports donc en fait on se
dit très bien on ne va pas pouvoir se
permettre de les attendre c'est à dire
que on va devoir nous la société civile
être ce contre-pouvoir fort on va devoir
s'emparer des solutions concrètes des
initiatives locales et pour ça comment
est ce qu'on fait j'ai reçu beaucoup de
messages de deux jeunes de moins jeunes
aussi de gens vraiment de tous les
niveaux sociaux ce qui était assez
dingue et de tout même de partout en
france en fait c'était absolument pas
centré spécialement sur paris et me
disais mais qu'est ce que je fais et
donc je me suis dit ok il faut qu'on
fasse une plateforme ce qu'on a fait ça
c'est pas l'inde discorde c'est
simplement un endroit on peut discuter
entre eux tous les associations qui ont
besoin de main d'oeuvre ont besoin de
gens qui viennent les aider ont besoin
de fonds parfois de dons et puis ben ces
personnes qui veulent aider ou qui
veulent trouver autour d'eux des gens
qui pensent comme eux et qu'ils peuvent
qui vont avoir envie de monter des
initiatives concrètes locale parce qu'on
a vraiment plus le temps qu'est ce qui a
selon vous a manqué qu'est ce qui manque
aux politiques justement pourquoi est ce
que pourtant quand on voit l'urgence
climatique le rapport du giec vous en
parliez troisième et dernière volée il
est alarmant comme à chaque fois on a
trois ans pour baisser arriver à un
degré et demi c'est comme si on voit les
chiffres on dit mais pourquoi les
politiques ne prennent pas la mesure 2
qui est en train de se passer c'est une
question qui m'obsède je ne comprends
pas pourquoi on nettement tout on n'est
pas en train de paniquer de sortir dans
la rue d'arrêter tout ce qui est en
train de faire et j'ai l'impression de
voir un espèce de tsunami qui arrivait
qu'on est quelques uns à le voir et que
les gens continuent tranquillement dalle
est resté sur les terrasses de café je
trouve ça hallucinant et en même temps
je pense que ce qui manque en tout cas
vraiment à ses dirigeants c'est de
l'humilité pourquoi c'est parce que
c'est très compliqué pour eux d'intégrer
que oui l'homme ne va pas être capable
de tout sauvé par son génie par sa
technologie que non il va réellement
falloir être dans la sobriété les gains
énergétiques qui va réellement falloir
regarder les solutions que nous offre la
nature qui va réellement falloir mettre
une pause et ralentir et ça c'est
extrêmement difficile pour des
personnalités qui sont nés dans cette
idée d'une croissance infinie d'une
d'une puissance totale et ça je pense
qu'il est vraiment une question même
philosophique à résoudre alors vous vous
parlez de ce tsunami qui arrive j'aurai
envie de comparer ça avec le film qu'on
a joui de dicaprio donc look up ou cette
comète arrive sur la terre et puis en
effet la vie continue en tout cas pour
beaucoup de gens alors vous vous avez
décidé de mettre une mobilisation en
place ça s'appelle look d'un de regarder
en bas pour défendre les profondeurs
c'est en référence encore une fois à ce
film de l'oned avec leonardo dicaprio on
va regarder tout de suite un extrait de
la vidéo qu'on peut découvrir sur votre
compte instagram et on en parle tout de
suite après
ceci n'est pas un trou noir
un film disney sur l'espace
ou encore le fin fond du cerveau de
soleil
[Musique]
ah ah oui d'accord ce sont les abysses
les profondeurs de notre océan
un cours à vide
jusqu'à ce qu'on commence à s'y
intéresser
[Musique]
il a bis désigne une zone océanique qui
englobe tout ce qui se situe en dessous
de 200 mètres de profondeur alors je
rappelle que cette vidéo vous l'avez
fait après le one ocean summit à brest
puisque c'était le premier sommet
mondial sur l'océan et encore une grosse
déception de l'état français de la part
de l'état français puisqu'il concerne
l'exploration et exploitation des faux
marin le moratoire n'a pas été signé
alors où en est votre mobilisation
lanvallay à lisbonne bientôt parce qu'un
nouveau gros sommet qui existait en fait
ce qui est assez dingue et pourquoi on
appelait loup dingue c'est parce que
pour ceux qui ont vu le film et je vous
paye pas grands enfants disent enfin
c'est simplement que on a on avait vu
des mémoires sur une comète et bâle a en
fait on a trouvé au fond des océans
alors que c'est une surface qu'on
connaît moins que la lune donc on ne
connaît absolument pas la seule image
que vous voyez c'est on n'a pas la
connaissance même scientifique pour
savoir qu'est ce qu'on va ou non
menacées et en fait les océans c'est
quand même c'est quand même la
principale nos principales alliées face
aux dérèglements climatiques parce qu'il
l'absurde une énorme partie de notre
carbone de co2 et donc en fait en allant
avec des énormes aching racler les fonds
marins pour pour du profit finalement on
risque peut-être de libérer dans
l'atmosphère le co2 donc c'est
extrêmement dangereux et du coup c'est
pour ça qu'on demande à ce que la france
rejoigne un moratoire il ya par exemple
l'espagne que c'est une très bonne
nouvelle car rejoint par un décret royal
le moratoire donc c'est à dire on va se
laisser quelques années dix ans voire
plus pour que les recherches avancent
c'est le minimum requis et la france en
fait qui comme une énorme puissance
maritime ne refuse de rejoindre ce
moratoire donc là là ce qui est très
important de comprendre c'est que nous
on fait beaucoup de lobbying en interne
etc mais tant que la société civile ne
s'est pas saisie réellement de cette
question parce que ça peut paraître
complexe selon nous les océans connais
pas trop alors que pourtant notre vie en
dépend donc c'est vraiment important
qu'on s'en saisissent et qu'on puisse
dire ce que vous faites on voit on vous
voit on vous regarde on vous laissera
pas tranquille encore une fois l'épreuve
les premiers projets peuvent commencer
dès jointe 2023 dans la zone de clint
heures clinton clipperton demain c'est
vraiment demain donc on a vraiment
besoin pour s'en saisisse de cette
question vous dénoncez également le
double jeu de la france dans le projet
icop à ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
ce qu'est ce projet et que fait emmanuel
macron merci d'en parler parce que c'est
j'ai encore une fois ça m'étonne à quel
point c la plus grande à mon sens bon
climatique et sociale de notre
génération et à quel point on en parle
très peu ce qui se passait assez
abominable c'est à dire qu'on à emmanuel
macron qui annonce vouloir être une des
premières nations à sortir des énergies
fossiles par ailleurs il a écrit une
lettre au président ougandais acer
élections pour lui dire quand on me fout
icop icop c'est quoi c'est le east
african queen sommes pas bons mois pour
lire moi voilà pour montrer que c'est
une super super moyens de renforcer la
coordination entre la france et
l'ouganda qu'est ce que c'est c'est
total une entreprise française qui est
en train de construire le plus grand
oléoduc chauffer au monde c'est 34
million de co2 de 2 2 tonnes de co2 par
an pardon qui sert à engendrer surtout
des centaines de milliers de personnes
qui doivent partir de leurs terres
laissées tout alors que l'ouganda est un
pays très agricole donc populations sont
attachés à leur terre il n'y a aucune
compensation de la part de total et des
violations de droits humains qui sont
faites sur place qui sont dénoncés par
des ong veut dire on passe à travers le
lac victoria donc si jamais il ya un
trou dans la plagne ses 40 millions de
personnes dans la dans la sécurité
alimentaire est menacée ce qui se passe
c'est extrêmement grave et total
continue à faire ce projet donc on
s'attaque aux banques pour qu'ils ne
puissent plus avoir de financement aux
actionnaires très bientôt ça que je
serai à l'ag de axa en quittant ce
plateau mais aussi surtout au soutien
diplomatique d' emmanuel macron qui est
extrêmement silencieux sur le sujet pour
l'instant on n'en parlait pas trop donc
qui se cachait derrière le on ne
soutient pas financièrement mais en fait
son soutien diplomatique et extrêmement
fort et c'est peut-être le tout début de
ce qu'on commence à découvrir donc on a
encore une fois vraiment besoin de
toutes les forces que soit
journalistique que ce soit de la
diplomatie que ce soit même populaire on
a vraiment besoin de se servir de ce
sujet parce que pour moi c'est une ligne
rouge qu'on ne perd ensemble pas
franchir merci beaucoup kamin etienne
d'avoir été avec nous on vous souhaite
bonne chance pour la suite et merci
aussi de prendre ce combat à bras le
corps parce que il faut il faut bien en
effet que que la jeune génération s'en
préoccupent sachez qu on est quand même
certains de la plus vieille génération à
s'en préoccuper aussi